as it turns out swalwell doesn't really
seem to care about violence against
elected officials
in 2018 remember maine senator susan
collins she got
she received a series of violent threats
this was during the
kavanagh confirmation when they were
smearing kavanaugh
lying about him while swalwall tweeted
quote again a senator threatened boo hoo
who you're a senator who police will
protect
wow as it turns out democrats never had
a problem with violent rhetoric
as long as republicans or conservatives
or donald trump are the target
in fact democrats have themselves as we
pointed out
frequently used aggressive hostile
rhetoric
to attack republicans and especially
donald trump
let's just take a look at a few of those
examples but we could spend the whole
hour if we had the time
take a look you cannot be civil
with a political party that wants to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
be careful
i i just don't even know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
maybe there will be
walk lightly you got to fight him in the
only way he knows how to fight and
that's the street
enough is enough if the president does
go ahead
and fire robert mueller we would have
people take to the streets i believe
there would be widespread civil unrest
we ain't playing with you even in states
where donald trump won big
that it does you any good running away
from donald trump i think you need to go
back and
punch him in the face make them pay
and what we've got to do is fight in
congress fight in the courts fight in
the streets fight online fight at the
ballot box
and for those of you who are soldiers
you know how to do it do it right
you know how to do it do it right
wow i'm going to take trump out tonight
remember that doozy maxine waters
now i would say everything you just saw
probably if we're going to apply the
same exact standard
well we'd be impeaching all of them why
for inciting
insurrection their favorite new word the
left has been viciously attacking
president trump the republican party
they spread nothing for three years but
lies and conspiracy theories
that trump was a russian agent asset not
true
only russian interference was hillary's
bought and paid for
dirty russian misinformation dossier
that was used to spy on the presidential
candidate trump
and president trump they accused all
republicans of being racist and sexist
and homophobic xenophobic islamophobic
they want dirty air and water you know
the list they said republicans were
going to destroy the country
throw granny over the cliff and take
away everyone's health care so you can
die
and in 2017 remember that deranged far
left gunman
targeting republican lawmakers on that
baseball field
friend of the show steve scalise nearly
died that day
he shot multiple people we saw how two
brave
capitol police officers in an open field
with only a pistol went up against a
rifle
totally risking their lives and getting
injured in the process
at the time president trump this show we
didn't blame democrats
nobody accused bernie sanders of
inciting that violence
instead president trump really released
this statement
now we may have our differences but we
do well and
one who serves in our nation's capitals
here because above all they love our
country
and as president donald trump always
well repudiated violence including last
summer
remember when the silence was deafening
from the media mob
and from democrats violent riots ripping
through
one american city after another city
after city after city
and president trump calling on states to
activate the national guard
he pledged his full support of the
federal government to restore
order law and order peace and
tranquility in cities and states
what was kamala harris doing she was out
there promoting that bail fund why
to get violent rioters out of jail
quicker
so they can rejoin their friends in the
effort and she said they're not going to
stop
we're not going to stop they shouldn't
stop we're not going to stop
wow other top democrats attacking
president trump for defending
american cities and stopping the rioting
and the arson
and the looting and the murder and the
two thousand twenty five hundred cops
injured during that time
in the weeks the riots of in downtown
portland week after week after week
multiple democrats condemning president
trump for sending federal law
enforcement officials
to protect a federal courthouse that
rioters were trying to burn to the
ground
almost every night watch this who
americans believe is the real
threat to our constitutional rights is
it the oregonians who gathered in my
hometown
in overwhelmingly peaceful protest for
racial justice
or is it the heavily armed secret police
who snatched portlanders off the streets
in the unmarked vans and interrogated
them
without justification here's what the
scene looked like
in portland when the federal troops were
arriving
thousands of people peacefully
protesting
can we move that into the picture
holding flowers
dancing chanting
arguing that we need to have a reform in
america so that there
is equal public safety for all
it's like fake news cnn and msnbc oh
it's been mostly peaceful
meanwhile the city's a blaze behind them
earlier that summer far left rioters
surrounding the white house remember
that
president is family inside for hours
they attempted to breach the perimeter
set up by the secret service remember we
were told the white house complex
plex faced the highest security alert
since
911.01 the president and his family were
rushed into a secure bunker
after fears that the perimeter would be
breached and not hold
not be held this happened only a few
months ago
nobody on the left seemed to care where
was the outrage from democrats
when this sacred building was attacked
where was the outrage when far left
rioters showed up
at senator josh hawley's front door
harassing his wife and young child
by the way senator hawley's wife will
join us tonight
where was the outrage when senator
mcconnell's house was vandalized or he
was confronted in a restaurant
where was the outrage when rioters
showed up at lindsey graham's home
where was the outrage when kirsten
nielsen and sarah sanders were accosted
at restaurants with their families
where was the outrage when rand paul and
his wife were attacked
after the rnc where was the outrage when
rand paul
was viciously assaulted by a neighbor
that's the one that left him with six
broken ribs congresswoman omar actually
quote
joked about that on twitter so tonight
the same democrats who condoned or
ignored
all of this summer's violent riots and
ignored the attack on the white house
and ignored the harassment
and attack against republican lawmakers
and called
on their followers to fight like hell
just like donald trump
these same democrats now accusing the
president of inciting insurrection
because he told his supporters to fight
like helen in the same speech
it turns out he says to be peaceful and
patriotic and let your voice be heard
the president's speech doesn't i guess
qualify as incitement does it
according to if you want to look at the
law brandenburg v
ohio a speech can only qualify for
incitement if it
is directed at producing imminent
lawless action and is likely to produce
such
action in other words a political speech
telling people to peacefully
patriotically let your voices be heard
is not incitement not even close and
it's not insurrection
and that's why democrats are attempting
to now shift the accusations of real
time
away from the president's actual words
slice dice and edit
into more of a smear into everything
he's done and everything i don't like
about him
about voter fraud election
irregularities kind of sounded like
hillary and stacey abrams to me
if voicing election concerns is a high
crime and misdemeanor
well then i guess abrams and clinton
will be held accountable
not only is the shifting impeachment
narrative getting sloppy
so is the evidence because we're
learning that one tweet used by the
impeachment managers was actually
altered or falsified
another problem arose when the
impeachment managers
entered another piece of false evidence
into the record about mike lee
they falsely claimed that president
trump called him and was briefed about
the situation in the capitol
that's also false